so norman
yes it's been a a week or so how many
days has it been since we talked
i think it was last tuesday when we
talked and uh
it's been two years yeah about a week
and a half and
what's going on well what's transpired
is uh
i looked at all the comments and uh
they were they were heartfelt they were
very inspiring
to the point to where you're looking at
a man who has compiled eight days
sober as of today you haven't used in
eight days eight days
not beer no marijuana no crack no
nothing
wow i've uh i don't know if you guys can
tell but my face is fatter
because i've just been eating been
eating a lot
and um but i feel really good you know
um
yeah you sound different you called me
last night you sounded like
so clear yeah like yeah yeah it's there
i mean and um it's um it was attributed
to the comments that i got
and um yeah you got a lot of positivity
and also
uh that good word it was the wherewithal
within myself that's right i said you
know what i really don't want to do this
anymore
i mean i have people who don't even know
me
that listen to me and
they gave me hope they gave me
inspiration and i truly believe that
when your hope is reborn
so is an opportunity to transform your
life so my hope is
is being reborn and my self-esteem is
being rebuilt because
you have to look at self-esteem it's
self-esteem
so therefore no one else can knock me
down but me
so what do i want to do and here i am
that's great
i think you're you know you're ready
perhaps
and this was maybe just the impetus to
to get your [ __ ] together yeah i think
it was one of those things where i had
to
really talk about the issues um one
person had mentioned in a comment maybe
i need to see a therapist and i'm
looking into that
that's always great i really want to um
i really want to do something better uh
also add some other good news uh
tuesday i have a video interview per job
for a job
as a property manager of 11 different
units
how did this come about well it came
about that day two of my sobriety i
went on indeed i activated my resume
and i said you know what i don't want to
be one check norman anymore
you know i want to be able to be a
productive citizen i want to do
something maybe my talk can inspire some
people maybe
maybe i might get into a position to
where even if i get this job
maybe a tenant has a problem with a
relative
that is suffering and maybe i can add
you know some type of inspiration or
some hope and maybe they just need
somebody to talk to
and you know hopefully pray for that i
can be that well of
the 2000 interviews i've done
in the last 10 years when i was
listening to yours it was just like
this guy nails it better than anyone
i've spoken to in every
from every angle when you mentioned
wherewithal that was it that was it
yeah yeah
no one has ever really mentioned that in
any of my talks that to me is the most
important
yeah not that i'm you know i'm not a
drug user so i don't even know but but
but i know what it takes to like make
anything happen yeah it's not talent and
it's not
it's not intelligence it's courage
certainly but but really the core of a
lot of that
in therapy and getting the crap out of
your closet and all that stuff but but
the wherewithal
right which is the ability to do it
right to get off the bed and go do it
every day
is to me one of the most important
things that people don't understand yeah
an obstacle that i have is um you know
as far as housing is concerned
i mean i can stay with my buddy you know
maybe three nights a week
you know so there's going to be points
where i'm going to but you've done this
before
yeah you you know how to be a
responsible citizen yeah where i have to
we're probably going to have to catch a
train sleep on the train a little bit
uh catch the bus look at it as a
challenge there there's going to be an
obstacle
nobody says it's easy it's like a grand
chess match you know
it's like i've made a move now here
comes another move
you know it's not so much of trying to
get the checkmate
but it's guarding it's that card that i
got to put up so
um i did call um lhasa
um i left the message uh maybe they can
help me as far as some housing is
concerned
um we're just gonna do it man i mean
it's it's
you're talking about 30 plus years on
and off up and down
uh my kids need me i did have a chance
to talk to
my oldest daughter she was very happy to
hear from me she told me she loved me
and that made me feel real good
uh i had a chance to talk to my son
who uh is the only son that i have he
says i don't give a damn what you do
you're always gonna be my father and
that was good and uh for you
sir you uh
you're almost you might be a
photographer but i'm gonna call you a
therapist
and because what you did for me is you
allowed me to
to really get some [ __ ] out you know
you know because i didn't want to tell
anybody about molestation i didn't want
to tell anybody about
you know i let a god give me some head
for some money because i'm looking at
what you're going to think about me
and what you're going to say about me
you know image is everything now i'm a
homeless crackhead but energy is
everything well guess what
i don't give a [ __ ] what you say about
me what you say think and feel about me
there's two things the most important
this is none of my business
the second is you're going to say what
you want to say you're going to be
judgmental and
if you're going to be judgmental in life
you probably headed down a bridge that's
going to
soon blow up so man i just
thanks no i think you know you're not
the first person that's told me they
stopped using after talking and it's not
that i'm doing something magical i think
it's maybe i'm not very
judgmental and that that opens the door
for you to tell me all kinds of dirt
that's in your closet
but it's that unloading of all your bags
that
frees you up to go oh
i don't have to hide that any longer why
and and
putting it on a platform like youtube
where basically in theory the entire
world
the entire world knows now what you've
done yeah and that frees you up to
to not carry that heavy baggage around
there were there were a couple of
comments decisions like you just did
yeah there were a couple of comments
where people were saying well that's not
the truth
then there was one person every single
one of my videos on my channel
is not i i consider that no they're not
fully uploaded until there's a comment
saying it's all it's a lie
right so one guy said that he said look
him up
it's true look at his facebook page and
then the other guy says
get this boy back he's a billionaire
he's connected to exxon
you know which uh a family member
founded humble oil which is now exxon so
so i come from good stock and and you
know but
sometimes i'm gonna put this
if you turn the pot off you're not gonna
have a fully cooked meal
my pot has been turned off
god has empowered me
to reach over to the stove
but when i reach over to the stove it's
not me guiding my hand it's him
see i don't always have to have it on
high to have a quick meal
i can turn it on medium and cook it
fully so
i believe i'm being fully cooked i don't
know where this stuff comes from it just
comes out of my head you know so
i just want to do the best i can and uh
we're going to follow up again probably
yeah because they're probably going to
say well hey we want to hear from norman
and that was really really great i think
you know in all of my life and being uh
in the upper echelon of companies and
things like that you never get a chance
to really
see how people feel about you now these
are people who don't even know me
and really really that was positive and
it turned me
it turned me on my buddy was like norman
are you all right and i was just sitting
there and i got tears just running down
he's like man what's wrong i said it's
over
he says what i said it's over
he said i knew it he said i knew it
i knew it was going to happen sooner or
later and it doesn't matter if he
doesn't stop
it maybe it's not his time and there's a
scripture
that keeps ringing in my head
ecclesiastes three one
there's a time a purpose and a season
for everything
so i think this is my time i don't fully
understand or really know my purpose
but it's his season i'm gonna do the
best i can
you've got everything it takes i think
yeah well
sometimes you can have everything that
it takes and it'll take away
yeah you know uh i'm a very prideful
person which now my pride is being
stripped
because it's it's something that has
been not so much of an anomaly for me
but it's been
something that has held me back you know
um of course you know
being uh able to to travel and do all
these things and
come from this family and all that i've
been able to uh
you know enjoy the finer things of life
you know and there were times where
i had a very pompous arrogant attitude
you know
in the rooms of recovery they say ego is
edging god out
i says okay well you know what
i believe that god and i have really
settled our problem because
i had the problem with him he never had
a problem with me
and so i asked him i said look if you're
real
if you are who you say you are stop me
stop me and you just work
you work in me and i'll work for you
i don't want anymore i don't have a
taste for it i can have money right now
i don't want it i've been offered it one
guy he just couldn't believe it he
followed me all the way down street
norman what's wrong with you
you don't want any dope dude what's
wrong i said man i don't want anymore
i said and i'll see you later and i
remember walking down the street about
20 yards and i turned around and he
looked at me
and he just shook he said he says okay
man and he walked away
so and that's how you quit that's it
that's it i just no that's how you do it
yeah because a year or two week ago i
couldn't
get you to go to rehab i couldn't just
or somebody couldn't
point you to the rehab and say go do it
there was a time where you know because
i work down here
you know so a lot of people know me and
i've used down here of course and done
other things um
there was a time where if you came up to
me and you were in recovery
i don't want to hear that [ __ ] if you
don't have anything to contribute to
what the hell i'm doing
just get the hell away from me i wasn't
rude but i'd let you know hey look
you know i'm doing this right now uh you
know now you got 10 15
to help me fine if you don't goodbye
cause i'm going back over here and sit
down and please leave me alone because
you're ruining my high
so um i just want to do the best i can
and and you know you can't ask for
anything else
or anything more really you just you go
gotta have it wherewithal i'm gonna mess
around and get a [ __ ] t-shirt put
wherewithal on it
and i'm for where we're falling we'll
put the number one on there because it's
gotta be
in here and i'm gonna tell you something
that i had six years ten months and two
days before
and i remember that i remember how
arrogant i got and things like that and
i fell
but you know what i've never felt like
this
even in those six years ten months or
two days i didn't use
but there was always an inkling of a
thought
well i only have been over only so over
eight days some people might come and
say well you only got eight days what
about day number nine you know what
i'm gonna take it a day at a time if i
may be i mean there's no idea
cliche i mean just do it norman just
just there's no arrogance in here right
now it's all humility yeah just take it
a day at a time i mean you put a video i
don't know if this company that's going
to video
has seen it i don't know
i'd be more likely to hire you and if
they did i'm going to tell you ask me
that's me and i'm more than likely going
to ask do you still have that problem
well it's not so much of a problem
you'll always have
the disease but it can be arrested
it could be put to death and the only
way it can be put to death is just
following god's
will because he already see the book has
been written already
front to end so now i'm in chapter one
the reason why i'm in chapter one is
because i'm i'm restructuring
recreating and redoing my life so now
i'm in chapter one so chapter one
basically has instructions that i have
to do
you know so i just follow him day that
day you know uh
i've never experienced this for humility
in my life um
i'm humbled as a piece of cheese on a
rat trap i'm just you know that's
oh my god it's like when i did that
interview it's like
here's a they just start getting off
you know and i just i felt different
when i left
did i use that day hell yeah i used that
day but it wasn't it was something wrong
it wasn't the dope it was me
and my buddy man you all right i'm like
yeah i'm okay but i wasn't okay
that night i stirred around i wasn't
okay
next day i stirred inside wasn't okay
and it's like it's time that's what i
heard
it's time the time is now
like okay so so what if i'm 56 years old
and starting again
damn if you're doing damned if you don't
and it was a phrase that my grandmother
used to use
she said sweetheart whatever you do in
life
do it to the best of your ability and if
nobody else likes it
mother had him mother love him and
[ __ ]
in saying that i had to really
understand what she was saying
don't worry because they're going to be
the naysayers
it's like the sadducees and the
pharisees see it's
just like this that is now
it's like the same thing so you're going
to have them
what are you going to do are you going
to succumb to their thoughts and
feelings of you
people have their own attitudes values
beliefs and prejudices that's just how
it is
that's life so you know what i'm gonna
take it a day at a time
do the best that i can do and uh
i would really like to ascertain a job
come in here and do an interview in a
suit i'd like to have you back about 50
times
oh yeah i'll be back as much as you want
you have my phone number uh people out
there
you have my phone number you can call me
you can text me you know i have a phone
that i haven't sold
isn't that something because i don't
give a damn if it's a it's an obama
phone [ __ ] it got to go
too if i need a hit but i have a phone
so i can contact people so people can
contact me
you know those comments really really
i'll be damned
it's about it's almost a thousand right
now and i'll read them over
and over again i get teary-eyed every
time
you know but there's all you can do it
you can do it so many people i interview
will get similar kind of reactions
from the commenters but they won't they
won't allow themselves to read them
i read them and i comment and that's and
that's the big indicator
i'll say thank you you know i yeah
that's a big indicator of whether
they're
ready for right to get clean because if
you're not
willing to accept that positivity you're
not gonna yeah you're [ __ ]
you're screwed you're [ __ ] you might
as well uh but the fact that you're like
like
you and eric another guy i speak to the
fact that you guys engage in the
comments
tells me yes you're you're already
healed yeah you're just going to follow
through with that and yeah in a year
it'll be a very different story yeah i'm
just going to keep on going and
as many times as you want to see me you
got my number i'll be on here i mean
you know somebody else may be suffering
i'm not going to say like i've suffered
but like i'm suffering see god i don't
want to i want to make sure that the ing
stays in there because the ed is his job
there's a difference between recovering
and recovered
you know one guy mentioned on there well
he's using all the treatment logo
well okay if you've been in 54 treatment
centers of course you can remember some
[ __ ]
you know but here's a book that i'm
going to start following
that was written in 1936
by bill wilson but i'm in that book
now how the hell am i in a book that's
written in 1936 same behaviors
same beliefs same actions
just because bill drank like he drank i
smoked
like i smoked basically i smoked like
bill drink
what's the book alcoholics anonymous oh
i see
excellent book excellent book excellent
book um
it doesn't get them it doesn't get
enough credit um
written in acronym ohio in 1936 i
says unbelievable i'm born in 1964. i'm
sitting before you in 2020
but i'm about to follow the instructions
and the guidelines of a book written in
1936.
why because i'm in it i'll take take the
alcohol just put a line through the
alcohol put crack
exactly the same you know exactly the
same
uh page 52 middle paragraph it says
selfish and self-centered that which is
the root of all our problems
driven by a hundred forms of fear
self-delusional
we step on the toes of our tel our
fellows and they retaliate
seemingly without provocation what we
invariably find at some point in the
past
we made a decision based on self which
later on put ourselves in a position to
be hurt
that has stuck in my mind for the last
eight days you know why
because i found that at some point in
the past
july 19 1986 i made a decision
based on self which later on here i am
2020 put me in a position to be hurt
hurt how
hungry homeless jobless afraid
hopeless now i'm hopeful
it's uh it's going to be a damn good
ride and i just thank god for giving me
the strength and his empowerment and his
wherewithal
to have me sitting right here eight days
consecutive with nothing it's so great
yeah norman thank you so much man ain't
no problem
not at all thank you bro it's beautiful
we're gonna we're gonna do this man
good for you it's gonna be all right bro
you